there was a long second where the five
thugs stared at the knife on the floor
at amos's feet and he stared back at
them
the emptiness in his belly was gone the
hollow space behind his sternum
gone his throat had stopped hurting
who's next he said flexing his hands
his face in a grin he didn't know he had
they came in a rush
amos spread his arms and welcomed them
like long lost
lovers and welcomed them he did and man
everything looks great in this season so
far
and holy mackerel things are about to be
a lot different for the inner planets
kind of makes me want to grab a bottle
of firehawk whiskey and go drown my
sorrows over by the augustin gamora
memorial
hey guys pete here gonna break down the
first three episodes of the expanse
season five which just dropped on amazon
prime video
exodus the churn and mother did a pretty
good job of setting the table across
a lot of different individual story
lines the crew's broken up
everyone had to get to where they're
going but things look as though they're
really going to pick up from here
this video will include spoilers from
everything that's happened in the
expanse tv show
up until this point so that's your
warning and as someone who's read all
the books i'm gonna refer to them
but won't be giving away any future
spoilers
there's a lot to cover since we got
three episodes so let's get right into
it
episode one opens following rock number
9 which is an iron nickel core and this
is 173 days after it was launched
towards earth
apparently it got too close to the sun
and broke up the science vessel
the uns hassami picked up the debris
near venus
but before they can figure out what
they're looking at they get boarded by
filipinaros
and his free navy crew after making sure
the hassani crew doesn't know anything
about the rocks
he kills them and takes the ship's data
cores we see that naomi son is ruthless
and dedicated to this
cause and he even has to leave one of
his crew behind as the ships destroyed
over at taiko we learned that the
rasanante is in for repairs they're
extensive it's gonna take time
we're introduced to a couple new
characters here we meet sakai who's
working on the ship and we meet bull
who is now working for fred johnson and
this is a repurposing of a character
that played a large role in the third
book his story was mostly absorbed into
the character we now know as drummer
and what's funny here is that he's
playing the role that her character
actually played when she was first
introduced in the books
we follow naomi and we see her find out
where her son is through fred johnson
and learn that amos and alex have
already left
naomi buys the ship chesmoka with the
intention of going and finding philip
from holden's perspective we see that
colonization is
in full swing colony ships are going
through the ring gates
people are trying to stake their claim
in these new systems
he runs into monica stewart she's asking
questions about the protomolecule
he reassures her that all the active
samples have been destroyed
but then she sort of baits him telling
him that she knows something about tests
that are going on
that gets him to go to fred and ask him
about his protomolecule sample
he tells them it's secure but not to ask
where it is then he shows him that elvia
koye still on illus doing tests on the
bullet the weapon that destroyed the
ring builder's civilization
fred asks him if whoever did that is a
threat to humans
holden says that every time he passes
through a ring it's like he passes
through their world he sees them
and each time he sees them he thinks
they look angrier
he thinks that going through the rings
is waking them up and he thinks that
whatever happened with him and miller
it's changed his brain so that he can
see them fred isn't convinced at all
no more of these artifacts have shown up
on the other worlds they've visited
nobody's been killed by a bullet yet and
until they can finish the navy they're
building
so that the opa can police the rings and
the belt without any interference from
the inner planets
he's not willing to give up his
protomolecule sample naomi tells holden
that she's leaving and then she doesn't
want him to come along
and we see her depart tycho for a palace
station
and can see that holden isn't taking it
well elsewhere we catch up with amos as
he's traveling back to earth i opened
the video
with an excerpt of the chapter where he
gets into this fight on the transport
ship
because if you haven't read the books
you are actually missing a layer here
because this was the first time we got
point of view
amos chapters where we hear what he's
thinking in the show's version of events
he just comes off as a badass who
doesn't want to pay these thugs who are
shaking everybody down for insurance
it still makes for a great scene but in
the book we had the setup that he was
feeling
physically sick but at the same time
knew that he couldn't be coming down
with something because he had already
taken all the boosters and medications
that you do
and he hears lydia's voice in his head
telling him you're not getting sick you
feel sad
so that whole line about him provoking
these guys to get into the fight
and then opening his arms and welcoming
them like long lost lovers
this is all sort of his way of working
his way through it
but he does make it to luna we see him
carrying the bag that had mercury's name
on it with his name written over top
which is awesome
we get this amazing introductory
sequence where we see the moon in all
its glory
we catch a glimpse of the augustin
gemara memorial
which is a really interesting easter egg
because this is the ship that marco
anaros
tricked naomi into writing the code that
caused it to blow up in dock on the moon
so that's a memorial to the worst thing
that naomi ever did
and a lot of people were killed in that
amos is met by security and he's taken
to see
avasarala who wants to know why he's
going to earth she wants to know if it
has something to do with holden
he tells her the truth that he's going
there because this woman lydia who took
care of him when he was young
after his mother died herself has passed
away and he's going there to tie up the
loose
ends of that they have a great exchange
where he calls her chrissy and she tells
him that she's a member of parliament
not his favorite stripper
and he responds that she could be both
we see that avasarala is having trouble
transitioning from being in charge of
everything all the time
we meet this new character delgado who's
working with her
they talk about the hasami which we saw
phillip take out in the beginning
she has suspicions about that and we see
her watching a feed where she's looking
into marco
alex makes it to mars apparently he's
bringing the razor back there for bobby
avasarala gave that to her it's kind of
funny when he's being cleared to land
the guy on the radio tells him that if
he would have brought the tachi they
probably wouldn't let him do
that of course that's the original name
of the rosannante before they salvaged
it
he has a plan to go see his ex-wife she
doesn't want to see him
that goes about as good as you think
something like that might then he goes
to meet with bobby where she acts really
weird
tells him that things aren't going her
way and basically shits on him for his
idea of going to see his wife and his
kid
we saw that she's been working on behalf
of abasarala looking into all these
black market weapons deals where people
are selling off martian firepower to the
belt
and when alex walks away we see him
looking around and you can see that mars
is dying a lot of the places are closed
down
things are emptying out and it's a
pretty tough situation there since the
ring gates open
we even saw a size family from last
season
messaging bobby thanking her for helping
them get out there through the ring
gates
at the end of episode one we get a
preview of where those rocks that marco
threw at the end of season four or
at of course we saw number nine break up
so we can imagine there's at least nine
if not more
there's eight that are lined up with
earth in the season four finale
but in this shot we see several of them
along with their projected impact time
we see
that they're pointed at different
locations and we see one that says 12
days 7 hours
one that says 14 days 4 hours 14 days 22
hours
15 days 3 hours and the last one i could
make
out said 24 days four hours so we know
that they're coming and we know their
impact is spaced out
episode two opens up with one of those
colony ships being taken by pirates
we see kamina drummer and her ships show
up
to levy a 10 tax on the pirates for
operating in their area
so my take away from this is that
drummer is now a pirate she's the
captain of the ship the dewalt
they have another one called the motang
and her crew is made up of her
family because she's in a plural
marriage with all these people
so we get a brief introduction to what
their life looks like
interestingly one of her partners is
named michio pa
which is another character that they
sort of absorbed into drummer
when they first introduced her so this
is a character that
book readers will be paying attention to
in the scene we also find out that they
located the tynan and that is ashford's
ship so they'll go looking for that
following amos we get another amazing
introductory shot of baltimore this time
we get a brief introduction to what
earth looks like he goes to lydia's
place and he meets
charles who's a man who's been with
lydia for the last 10 years they lived
together
initially he's suspicious of him because
the thing is amos came to earth because
he wanted to find out how lydia died and
if he found out something happened to
her
he was gonna kill everyone involved this
was his explicit plan
as they're talking we see this shift in
amos at the moment that he realizes
charles was good to her that he did care
for her
and that she died of natural causes and
aneurysm
and nothing funny happened he finds out
that charles is losing the house
because this guy eric who was taking
care of her was no longer going to keep
it after she passed away
amos tells him to stop packing and then
he goes to look for eric
and we get another badass scene where he
makes himself known to a street dealer
telling him if he wants to be his friend
that he'll get word to eric for him
that works out he meets eric at his
office and in the show's version of
events we get an idea that they have a
history that amos made the choice
to kill their boss rather than kill him
and then he helped amos take their
boss's identity
and get off the planet and that's why
when monica was asking him
questions about his past she brought up
the name amos burton
in relation to a mob boss in baltimore
we learned that
amos's real name is timothy and we see
that eric is afraid of him but once he
realizes that all he really wants is for
him to take care of the old man
he agrees to do that but tells amos that
even though he loves him even though he
misses
him if he comes back to his city he'll
take him out
we have been seeing amos having these
visions of his younger self and lydia
around the city we see one more
flashback where he's talking to her
and we see they have a strong bond that
she agrees to take care of him
it's less than what we learn about him
in the books and i don't want to spoil
that because we still might get to that
over the next couple episodes
but generally speaking he seems to have
done what he came there to do
he's ready to leave earth for good but
he contacts
absarala and tells her there's one
person he does want to see
and he needs your help to get that set
up
on taiko the rossi repairs are ongoing
holden is there missing his crew
he gets a message from monica that sucks
him in
because she feels like she can prove to
him that somebody's going after the
proto-molecule
when he goes to look for her he finds
out that she's been kidnapped
she was in a shipping container and
after busting into the wrong one they
find her
in the nick of time they save her life
on mars bobby and alex get back together
she explains what she's been doing
shows them all the weapons she's bought
and she tells them about this guy
sovitary alex knows the name he thinks
he can get the guy to talk to him and he
goes to see him talk
at the war college we see this guy is
high ranking he's well spoken
he definitely has an interest in the
rings and how they change
things but when he approaches him he
won't give alex the time of day instead
emily babbage comes up to him says that
she'd love to talk
and then later we see that she's doing
that for soviet terry to figure out what
alex is doing on the planet
on luna avasarala is trying to warn
nancy gal and the other members of the
un
that something's going on nobody wants
to listen to her
delgado is still working with her and
they're still looking into marco
in episode 3 they meet with an outside
scientist to ask questions about the
hasami
the information they get there combined
with what she's hearing from bobby on
mars
convinces her that there's something
going on we see drummer and her crew
find ashford's ship
she finds the message that he left as he
was being spaced by marco and that
convinces her to go
after him for the bounty not everyone in
her crew thinks it's a good idea
and we see a lot of great drummer in
this episode we get to see the other
side of her
we see how she's dealing with losing
ashford we see one of her partners
oksana
try to talk her out of going after marco
saying that she's doing it for revenge
drummer tries to say that she's just
doing it for the money and they have a
moment together
that ultimately convinces drummer to
take the information she
has from ashford and send it to fred
johnson
after saving her monica shows fred and
holden footage she has of courtezar
being abducted he's one of the
researchers that had the procedure done
so that he
is a sociopath basically and he has
extensive experience working with the
proto-molecule he was last seen he was
abducted by anderson dawes
this video of him being abducted is from
series and her source tells her it's
from a research facility
this whole situation convinces fred that
there's something going on that there's
moles in tycho station
that have allegiances to more radical
factions of the opa
in their investigation to find out who
kidnapped monica
they find two dead bodies and then also
realize
that there's a ship coming to pick up
the container she was in
they're under the assumption that they
haven't realized that she's been rescued
yet so they're gonna wait till this ship
comes in
to get to the bottom of what's going on
on mars alex meets up with
emily who's effectively just shaking him
down for information
she's asking a lot of questions about
the proto-molecule what happened when
they got to illus
how they activated the structures that
were on the surface that were left
behind
when they're leaving he finds out that
the next day she's shipping out on the
bar keith
when he gets back to his room he's
attacked he's drugged with a sedative
that's basically like a truth serum so
he gives up all the information he has
he tells his attackers that he's
wondering if sovitera is selling weapons
and that he's involved with bobby draper
but then she shows up just in time to
save him
because they were going to execute him
after they got the information
after that's all said and done they make
a plan to follow the bar keith and the
razorback
naomi arrives at palace station she
reunites with old friends
sin and carl we had already seen them
working with philip
earlier and she tells them that she
wants to see him they end up meeting
and she makes a plea that she wants to
help him she wants to get him out she'll
give him the chet's mocha
so they can get away from his father and
do whatever he wants
he basically tells her to [ __ ] off that
she doesn't know what he needs
and that she knows nothing about him
later when she's on the ship he returns
and she thinks that he changed his mind
but instead he's there to take the ship
they take her prisoner basically
and she finds herself in a rough
position so at this point avasarala
probably has the best idea of what's
going on but as mentioned no one's gonna
listen to her
we see her reach out to arjun and we saw
her with her daughter earlier to kind of
underline the idea that her relationship
with him is suffering
because she won't put this job behind
her she tells them that she's still
needed there
and then she receives the message from
fred that has the information
from ashford that he got sent from
drummer
so all the pieces are starting to come
together and then that's where
things change we see this guy with his
fish finder 3000 glasses on looking at
the ocean standing on the beach
and we see the first rock enter the
atmosphere and crash to the earth
we see his face almost get instant
sunburn and we see the
reflection of the impact in his lenses
and at ground zero we see that he's just
blown away and i don't think i really
need to tell anyone
but it's fairly obvious that this is
gonna be a big issue for earth
the impact appears to be off the coast
of africa the sign we see here is in
zulu according to translate
and from the end of episode one we know
there are several
other of these following with the next
one coming
at the latest in two days based off the
ones that i could make out
so marco and the free navy were able to
pull off their attack
they stole the stealth technology they
put it on the asteroid and made it past
earth's defenses
and now we have to wait for a week to
find out what exactly that means
the loss of life will be devastating but
it's also the belters crossing a line
that many would consider unthinkable
earth is where human life developed it
wasn't just the first planet but it was
the only planet with the breathable
atmosphere before the ring gates open
as mentioned it's an attack that crosses
a line and it ensures that things will
never be the same
so there's a lot to take in here overall
i think they did a great job of having
so many different stories so many
different balls in the air they didn't
really drop any
the character work was all pretty
effective as a book reader
it's a little bit hard to say i was a
little underwhelmed with the amos stuff
compared to how i imagined it having
read the books and knowing what was
going on in his internal dialogue
the novella about him the churn sets up
the eric character
so i was expecting some more detailed
flashbacks to that
similar to how we saw other novellas
featured in earlier seasons
but having said that i think the way
that they played it out it still is
rather effective
and he's still on earth at this point so
there's more to come he's our guy on the
ground
the first rocks hit and he's gonna be
there to experience that
firsthand i was really curious to see
where they were going to go with drummer
and this is pretty interesting without
giving book spoilers there's a lot of
stuff here that calls back to characters
and i was a little bit concerned about
some of the stuff that michio pad did in
the book and how that really wouldn't
make sense for drummer so
we'll see how that plays out the belter
scenes all landed
we got a good introduction to philip and
his world seeing naomi arrive and go
through all of that hit and we can
imagine that she's due for a reunion
with marco
as well seeing drummer with her family
her polyamorous union
it does add to an already compelling
character on some levels
the way the belters live is always kind
of the most interesting just because
they live in space
but across the spectrum and all the
different locations we got to see
more of the way that people live it
seemed like in these three episodes
and it feels like a good way to ground
everything because we're gonna be able
to see people
experience this attack across all these
different locations
to amplify just how far reaching the
effects
are everything looked fantastic i think
these are three of the best looking
episodes they've ever put out
tycho and mars both look great and
especially earth and luna the only thing
i would complain about
is that as a recapper three episodes is
a whole lot of stuff
there's so many references and so many
things i'd like to dive into
but i think it's going to take some
bonus videos because there's so much to
cover in just the recap itself
i enjoyed these episodes i think it was
a great start really curious to see how
the mars story develops
soviet is a character that we know of
but he may be also absorbing some extra
roles here
also it was really interesting to see
cortazar show up so i'm
interested to see where they're going to
take that especially considering that
elvie is still involved in the story and
she's out there
studying the bullet and with that i
think i'll leave it there
let me know any questions you have about
all three episodes in the comments i'll
try to answer whatever i can
let me know what you liked the most what
do you think was the most interesting
what do you want to see in the rest of
the season please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already i'll be
doing plenty of expanse content
throughout this season all the way until
the show wraps up in season six
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon